we are here to talk about the best games
released in 2014 so far so far Tomic
shake Carolyn Pettit and Justin hey Walt
got a bunch of games to talk about today
be you folks are on to talk about three
in particular first of all a deal CPAC
yeah so we're starting this kind of a
weird one we're gonna start by talking
about less of us left behind and it may
or may not you know yeah just helps ya
for the actual game of the year award
the same [ __ ] Santa this year but we
we wanted to talk about it tom and i
think in particular our big champions of
this game because we just think that
it's one of the greatest achievements of
the year so far um it's it is just
remarkable story following I don't know
a lot of people haven't really gotten
around to it yet i've noticed maybe I me
included actually they might be waiting
for I mean last of us ps4 coming out
this month so but it's I mean it's
flushes out the story and the character
Ellie who's one of the best characters
ever just in a way that the main game
wasn't quite able to do right so I mean
the corgi in the last of us I think you
know he is an excellent example I've
like really traditional kind of triple-a
action-adventure game design where you
play through a section of and then
there's like a story cutscenes and then
you play through another section is more
cutscenes part of what makes left behind
I think so brilliant is the way that it
uses the gameplay mechanics that you
kind of get familiar with it throughout
the last of us in different ways to
build up the feeling you have as the
player of this bond between alien and
her friend Riley and so it just kind of
you know rather than using stealth like
hide from clickers or you know the
things you did in the normal game it's
like now you're playing a game of
hide-and sorry your friend or you know
tossing bricks at cars is this like
moment of bonding and the it's also
important to say but the quality of the
writing in this is truly exceptional as
far as games writing goes well from a
Sony exclusive to a a Nintendo exclusive
mario kart 8 k my last month it was the
autumn aesthetic the soundtrack of our
office for about two weeks as
Tom you were playing it oh yeah people
were getting involved in it and a lot of
some people think you know just another
mario kart why why do you think this
might be one of the best games releases
here uh you can make a strong case that
this is the best mario kart ever from a
pure racing perspective okay um you
could not make a strong case if that's
not true My Name Is It this is just the
best pure racer Nintendo has made or
published in sub-zero basically which
was which is while ago because like they
there's nothing else in this game except
for racing there's none there's no like
challenges or anything which we've seen
in other games like the DS version but
like they nailed the moment-to-moment
feel of driving so much and they nailed
the course design and it's just it's
really just a masterpiece and like that
regard of like they understood how to
make driving really fun and balanced and
on top of that I think it's also worth
noting that the design of visual design
of the game is just so so vibrant and so
beautiful it feels so satisfying to like
get getting first if you're behind
someone because you earned it I really
love that the blue shell and other games
has always been so ridiculously
overpowered and in this game they give
you the power to to overcome that
there's an item specifically where you
know you sound a horn and that will
repel the blue shell as it comes to
attack you and some people have also
found that you're able to boost if you
boost just right at the right time we
obviously doing em game of the month
here at gamespot com some of these games
they were going to talk about today have
one given one some haven't because it's
almost stronger than others yeah our
most recent one was shovel knight I only
actually scratched the surface of it and
immediately it just felt it felt like to
me like it could have been a classic you
know NES game like if this word game
that actually come out on the NES
because it it captures kind of that that
Megaman or you know as a side-scrolling
feel but it also has this kind of world
mapping these villages you go into that
are very reminiscent of Zelda to the
adventure of link and and so it just it
just uh it takes all of these familiar
elements from those games but it it
pulls them off so well that you know
it's just wonderful to return to them
it's like if people were still making in
the s games this is the game that they
would have made this is the natural
evolution extension well that might say
is there something different than about
because you know
you can say that you know remakes event
old NES games could be something quite
right or what is it about this is this
more than just a simple homage is it is
it actually something that feels like it
could have been released a better that's
actually the the beauty of it is this
this doesn't have anything else to it
like super time for one of the other
like great games that you're like that
couldn't have been made like that was as
completely new and inventive with the
time mechanic but this really is just
old school this is what NES games were
but it's a really good version of what
NES games were we're here to talk about
the best games released in 2014 very
happy to be John with Todd McShay Kevin
Hart and Shawn McInnis gentlemen their
logical games k made this year one of
the ones that I have on my list only
came here last week in fact Kevin you
were on this very show playing it
divinity originally so you I guess you
like it then it's really really really
good really really really long oh wow
just a moment what is it about this game
and thinks it could be a contender for
best game with you oh it's now the
combats really good number one it's got
turn-based combat like it's like from
Temple of Elm Elemental Evil kind of was
way back in the day except not broken
okay so no that's really good the
explorations really neat there's quests
everywhere you go there's something to
do and the interesting thing is the game
does it hold your hand for any of this
stuff like there are no real ever so
often like a waypoint type thing will
appear but typically no way points
there's lots of different ways to solve
quests depending on how you go about
things sometimes you can talk your way
out it has this cool rock paper scissors
system when you have two characters
talking to each other okay and base but
but that in itself is sort of based on
their stats for like I'm going to try to
out charm you oh I'm going to try to out
intimidate you so we're gonna do rock
paper scissors too and sometimes you do
that against like enemies and suddenly
it's like oh I don't have to fight these
dudes they're like oh i charmed my way
into their lair and I don't know when
someone has a layer you don't see too
much charming to get
there well you know trying to get you in
every layer I I magicked my way into
that layer I want to talk about another
game that involves digging up bones at
Wolfenstein Wolfenstein the order yeah
but I have play I really enjoyed
Wolfenstein are more wolfy times as we
call in this office they started playing
wolfy times on saturday it's fun so far
but why is it one of the best games
releases here what i really like about
it is it's a game that's it's very aware
of its own place in history it's
respectful of the Wolfenstein tradition
it embraces that kind of stuff but it
doesn't find itself like anchored down
by it like it actually it it pulls off
this balancing act between the bombast
and the machismo of like a vintage
shooter from the 90s but it's also a
game with a very interesting story and
very like BJ blaskowitz is a great
character in this game which is not
something that was expecting in the
least like this this game does like it
does downtime really well like very
often you go you spend time between
missions in the animal world it's it's
not a hub world it's like a resistance
hide out in the middle of Berlin and
it's like it's you just linger there for
a little while and you hang out with
these other resistance fighters and you
kind of see how they spend time you know
in the resistance it's it's it's really
really impressive and that's part of
what I really love about BJ blaskowitz
as a character in this game is that he's
he's really he's a really interesting
character but he's not like a guy who's
like weighed down by his own dark past
is that he's not like tormented by his
own like inner turmoil he's he's a guy
who as one of your side characters
remarks he was born to kill Nazis great
yeah speaking of Wolfie times Mary edit
it later the wolf among us wise now why
have one of the best game since eight
this year because i think overall even
though i was a little disappointed with
the finale i think overall it is really
one of those things where the journey
was totally worth it it wasn't really
about the destination especially because
the way it ends you might want to then
go back and replay stuff okay which is
not something that I usually like to do
with a telltale type game because i feel
like--okay out
my story I don't want to mess with that
story by like poking into the other
possibilities because then I like it's
just like kind of pulling the curtain
and seeing the wizard for me so but it's
it's really good I think the third
episode is actually the highlights or
episode yeah yeah so i would i would say
definitely especially because the world
is just really interesting about go to
the comics